Hey what's up guys it's Colin for theScore esports and who said flicks were just for AWPers?
Three weeks ago we gave you the top 10 AWP flicks in CS:GO, and this week,
we decided it was time to give rifles and pistols a little love as well.
So whether it's a 180 flick with the AK or a P2000 reaction shot that could be described
as inhuman, there's more to flicks than just the sniper rifle.
So sit back, hit that sub button and get ready for the Top 10 rifle and pistol flicks in CS:GO.
Kicking off our list is KennyS on Cobblestone. Who in a 1v3 landed this disgusting deagle flick onto MSL
before ending the game with an otherworldly flick onto Schneider.
(Casting)
From one prodigy to another, our number nine play sees Coldzera terrorize Tyloo.
Pinned between four players, Cold more than holds his own as he takes down DD,
before turning on BnTet with a filthy flick.
(Casting)
F0rest comes in at number eight on our list with a p250 flick that’s so fast,
you’ll need to see it a few times before it even registered.
No seriously, we needed to slow this down just
to see it.
(Casting)
At number seven we’ve got GeT_RiGhT with an unbelievable kill to open up the round.
Up 13-9 against SK gaming, the NiP legend landed an unbelievable upwards flick
onto fer that instantly ended his life.
(Casting)
Coming in at number six is yet another play from F0rest, who at IEM Oakland 2017,
surgically deleted Tarik with this gross deagle flick through the wall with just a sliver of vision.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 5 is Autimatic at Northern Arena Toronto.
The newest member of a revamped Cloud9 squad, Autimatic was looking to make a statement
with his new team and boy did he do just that as he conjured up this nasty flick onto Snappi.
(Casting)
At number four we have none other than ScreaM.
The “eddshot” machine secured an unfathomable kill that saw him run through mid doors to
delete fnx in mid air with an absolutely disgusting
flick.
(Casting)
At the number three spot is Team Liquid’s Hiko, who in a 1v3 pulls off this VAC-worthy
kill, as he instantly flicks onto AKis with just one bullet through the smoke.
(Casting)
Taking the runner up spot on our list is Adren, who puts on an absolute clinic by killing
two Wizards players, before ending the game in style with an unbelievable 180 flick that
left the casters gasping for air.
(Casting)
Coming in at the coveted number one spot is a flick, seen across the world.
A flick, that needs no explanation.
It’s Hiko’s inhuman reactions on Dust 2.
(Casting)
Well guys that's our list.
And if any of your favourite rifle or pistol flicks did not make it on.
Flick us a comment, and I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.